if it's not on the page it's not on the
stage it's an adage that dates back to
the earliest days of the movie business
and it's as true today as it was back
then
without the inspiration and perspiration
of the screenwriter directors would have
nothing to shoot and we actors would
have nothing to say here are the
nominees for Best Original Screenplay
Alejandro G Inarritu Nicolas jackar
bowmani Alexander denill eres jr.
Armando bow for Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance Richard
Linklater for boyhood
Emax fry and dan Futterman for
Foxcatcher wes anderson and hugo
guinness for the grand Budapest hotel
Dan Gilroy for Nightcrawler
and the Oscar goes to
Birdman the unexpected virtue of
ignorance
this is the first Oscar for Nicolas
Giovanni Alexander Jinnah lares jr. and
Armando bow including his nominations
this year for directing and Best Picture
this is the fifth nomination for
Alejandro G Inarritu and his first Oscar
wins
yes Wow
the journey of Birdman started three
years ago when I asked Niko Armando and
Alexander to follow me in a crazy idea
and because they are crazy they did it
and we wrote together a Birdman and and
for that I'm all my life grateful and
thankful for that to share this
experience with them we want to thank
our incredible cast Emma Naomi and drea
amy Lynn say mr. Norton sac and the
maestro of maestro's mr. michael keaton
with for making this film fly without
you guys we will not be here James Scott
stupid Jon Lester the producers and I
want to thank to obviously the great
support from our non milchin Brad
Western from New Regency and all the
team on Fox Searchlight Nancy oddly God
and Claudia Lewis and Steve Eagar Lula
and all the people to help us really
thank you very much for all the audience
to see this crazy film my kids
Eliseo Meryl Arya my wife Marie Larry I
think could be are very much for all
thank you this award wait wait
family time nyla Amalia and Elena my
daughter's work my reason TV Adrian
Clary mariana our dog Larry
big tortilla ganache a ribbon al cuarto
piezo luciana amadora Torino Anto
Argentina
you